The next phase is the reducer. In our case we
only have a single reducer because that's the HADOOP default. It
will get all the keys. The reducer is going to
get all the data coming in something like this. If we
had specified more than one reducer, each would receive some
of the keys along with the values for those particular keys.
We're using HADOOP streaming here because we want to write our code
in PYTHON. Hadoop streaming allows you to write your mappers and
reducers in any language, rather than forcing you to
use Java. But the way reducers get their data
is a little bit tricky. As you can see,
the data comes in streamed as lines of text.
Each line contains a store name and the cost.
The store names are sorted, which we're guaranteed because
of the shuffle and sort. So we know that
all lines for, say, Miami, are together. So if
we receive our data like this, what variables might we need to keep track of to
calculate the total sales per store? Do we need to know the cost of the previous
line? Do we need to store the current cost? Or how about the total sales per
store? Do we need to save the previous
store, or the store that we're currently working with?